The United Nations Film Board presents The
Eternal Fight
[Narrator:] Deliver us.
Deliver us from the plague, from hunger, from
war.
This has been the cry of mankind throughout
all time.
Blinded by ignorance, filled with terror,
he lashed out against the black plague with
witchcraft, against typhus with superstition.
And so maddened efforts to stem the terrifying
ravages of epidemics, prejudice, and intolerance,
too often resulted in cruel and vicious treatment
of those suffering from contagious diseases.
Despite the raging panic of ignorance, the
lurking danger of contagion,
scientists of many nations went to work.
Painfully they labored to nurse the flickering
light of research into a broad searchlight
of knowledge,
using every means of communication to share
their findings with each other.
It was the Dutchman, Leeuwenhoek, whose research
helped provide scientists everywhere
with a new and powerful vision of the microscope.
Now at last the hidden enemy could be examined
under the probing searchlight of science.
The hunt was on for contagious diseases and
their causes, wherever they existed.
[Narrator:] Spallanzani in Italy pioneered
the work on the origin and growth of microscopic organisms.
He proved that fermentation did not take place in sealed containers,
but occurred only through contact with the
microorganisms present in the air.
Jenner, in England, painstakingly evolved
the basic principles of vaccination,
and a little British girl was the first to
wince at the sting of a vaccinating needle.
And Pasteur in France, his was the brilliant
research that resulted in the discovery
of the causes of contagious diseases.
He proved that microbes were at the root of such diseases, and thus medical science marched forward
bringing light where once there had been darkness,
hope where once there had been despair.
And in Germany, Koch identified and isolated the Koch bacillus and the dreaded germ of cholera.
Across the sea in America, Walter Reed and
his colleagues sought to prove that the mosquito
was the sole transmitter of yellow fever.
They offered their lives, and won.
And so the old prejudices were smashed and the free exchange of information forged modern weapons,
like the ancient diseases of mankind.
Then, in the course of the nineteenth century,
the world underwent a striking change.
It gave birth to the Industrial Revolution...
transformed man's way of life.
Men, women, and children crowded into cities,
became part of a vast machine.
Deprived of sun and fresh nourishment of the
country, men's bodies rusted,
became more vulnerable to contagion.
New means of transportation brought the world
tight and close together, tremendous
making it one and congested city.
From a disease-infected zone the traveler
now became, unwittingly, a carrier of deadly germs.
Wherever he went the germs stayed and spread.
Epidemics break out far from the known infected
areas.
Country to country, continent to continent,
the deadly cargo of microbes is transported,
menacing on a vast scale the very existence
of humanity.
Mass infection and epidemics are a threat
to every city, to every nation.
Scientific and medical work on a local scale
are no longer enough.
Thus, in common defense, nations joined an international agreement in the battle against epidemics.
Medical agreements and protective measures
are formulated, quarantine measures extended,
frontier controls set up.
When an epidemic strikes, that country is
subjected to special restrictive measures.
Suspected carriers are isolated, and step-by-step, the dangers of contagion grow less and less.
War!
The first great World War, like all wars,
sucking mankind down to misery and death.
And together with war, pestilence, and disease,
epidemics wreak havoc greater than war, wipe out civilian populations.
The problem is everywhere and must be dealt
with internationally.
A network of medical information is swiftly
organized through radio, newspapers, pamphlets, bulletins.
The League of Nations spreads information
that all may fight the contagion of diseases.
In Geneva, this immense storehouse of information becomes part of the arsenal of embattled doctors
and scientists everywhere.
Heath reports are received, checked, filed,
collated, and sent out again ready for use.
Because now trains are entering and leaving
stations.
Ships leave and dock at foreign ports.
Millions live, work, and suffer.
For this sailor it's always hard to say goodbye.
Harder still when your wife is sick, burning
with fever, and you have to pull anchor.
There's nothing to worry about, you say.
She'll be all right in a couple of days.
Besides, you need the job.
But neither of you suspect...typhus.
The black plague.
And so goodbye.
Both have become carriers of death-dealing
germs.
Germs that will blast the lives of shipmates.
Germs traveling across seas to start a terrible
epidemic at any moment, any place.
Epidemic starts anytime, anyplace, wherever
you are, wherever she is now in a hospital.
There are no doubts, it is contagious.
Immediate action, a life at stake, and though
she might infect or has already infected,
Who is she?
A friend.
Her kinfolk.
Send the alert everywhere, to every nation,
to every port, in every language.
Easy enough to locate all ships which left
the area before the outbreak.
Message to all ships at sea.
The quarantine service must know the health condition of your ships in every port.
Every day, almost every moment, for epidemic
strikes any time, any place, wherever you are.
A protective mechanism is set in motion.
The quarantine service issues the necessary orders to the ship for investigation and control.
The ship is stopped, the sick man brought
ashore.
All others are fully protected by inoculation.
And now the ship is thoroughly disinfected.
Rats are hunted out of their hiding places.
Cyanide gas does the trick.
Teams of specialists fumigate the boat from
stem to stern, from staterooms to the hold.
Everything completely disinfected before the
ship is able to sail on in safety.
Such cooperation protects mankind from recurring
epidemics.
International cooperation provides immediate
action to smash a swift-striking enemy.
Today there are no distances.
Today the aeroplane links continents as trains
link cities.
Today the peoples of the world are one people
joined by wings over the globe.
Today people of all races, of every level,
move from country to country in a matter of hours.
Today vital medical control is established
around the modern points of international exchange, the airports.
The network of health information and services
has been extended here from the seaport organization.
But is this sufficient?
How long does it take before a potential epidemic
can be detected?
From one continent to another, only a few
hours flying time.
But cholera takes longer to show itself.
And yellow fever three to six days.
And the incubation period of smallpox from
seven to 16 days.
Passengers in a modern plane look perfectly
healthy.
They are, but how do we know?
That little girl, when she got the doll, did
she receive germs as well?
Some passengers may be germ carriers, perhaps
already in the incubation stage.
They'll reach their destination before any
symptoms show.
The quarantine service can't keep every plane
and passenger grounded for several days
to effect thorough medical control.
Today, that system of defense is no longer
enough.
Today, epidemics must be crushed at the very
source.
Unfortunately, in some countries, contagious
diseases exist in an endemic state.
That is, permanently.
India, for instance, has certain areas that
are always infected with cholera.
This plague can extend to Western Europe.
In Africa, some forms of malaria still rage,
germs that might easily be transmitted to South America.
And cholera in Japan could strike suddenly
at the west coast of the United States.
Permanently infected zones are localized but
may cover large areas of territory,
sometimes entire continents.
Modern transport poses new dangers of complete
universal contagion.
The struggle against epidemics is a global
one,
for the danger of death is worldwide.
Then...what is the answer?
Within the framework of the United Nations, a new organization exists
to promote the welfare of all people:
the World Health Organization.
It its first assembly, July 1948, Director-General Dr. Chisholm declared that this organization was physically prepared
to raise the health level of all people and
to forever destroy the human afflictions of
of malaria, cholera, tuberculosis, and syphilis.
The prime objective of the World Health Organization
is the fight against disease on a global scale.
The representatives of nearly every nation
have signed the great Charter of Health.
This means an organization with the authority
and means to act.
Epidemics, no matter what part of the world they may infect, are a potential danger
to all other nations.
The World Health Organization will make full use of every existing means: education, prevention, cure.
All peoples of every race and belief will
be helped by doctors from all races and nations.
A tremendous movement of world solidarity
is now born.
Inoculation already widely used will be extended.
Millions of people will be given prophylactic
injections.
A worldwide system of medical control will
exist everywhere.
Enormous quantities of serums, vaccines, new and powerful drugs such as penicillin and sulfonamides
are already being manufactured at increasingly lower costs.
Crates of ampules are shipped to all parts
of the world, ready for emergency measures.
A constant flow of up-to-date information
from every nation in every tongue
now makes it possible to apply the latest discoveries of modern medicine.
Cholera broke out in Egypt shortly before
the first assembly meeting of the World Health Organization.
The first cases were instantly reported, and
from Cairo every nation was immediately alerted.
New York was then the clearinghouse for the
incoming orders for vaccines and equipment
needed to fight the epidemic that was menacing
Egypt.
Dr. Calderon issued orders.
How about sulfadiazine, serums, needles, syringes,
anything else?
Anything.
Don't worry about the payment.
The World Health Organization will pay.
Let's get going fast.
The answer was swift.
From France, China, Indochina, Soviet Union,
and the United States,
vaccines were shipped by the fastest means.
Planes flew the precious fluid into Egypt.
They brought thousands of needles, syringes,
other indispensible instruments.
In record time, the Egyptian government had
the entire population immunized,
the sick put into isolation wards, and the
infected areas methodically disinfected.
The epidemic was checked,
and within three months completely eradicated
from Egypt.
In the eternal battle a struggle has been
won,
won by international cooperation.
But there is yet a tremendous task before
us, a task for all peoples, by all peoples.
The lives of these little children too must
be saved,
that a light of hope may revive the courage
of those who suffer.
That mothers might yet smile in a new world.